- [Teacher] I have five
three-dimensional shapes over here.
I also have five names for them.
What I want you to do is pause this video
and think about which of these
shapes is a square pyramid.
Which of these is a rectangular prism?
Which one is a triangular prism?
Which one is a sphere and
which one is a cylinder?
Let's just work through this together.
Really, this is just something to know,
because some people in various subjects
will sometimes throw out these words.
First, let's think about which
one is the square pyramid.
This shape here on the right
clearly looks like a pyramid,
and the thing that makes
it a square pyramid
is the idea
that its base is a square.
Let me see if I can shade this in.
So the base of this right over here
is a square.
That's where the square
pyramid comes from.
If it's a triangular pyramid,
then the base would only have three sides,
but this is a square pyramid.
So let me...
Move this over there.
So that is a square pyramid.
Alright, let's do the next one.
Which one is a rectangular prism?
A prism you can view as a
three-dimensional object,
and since it's saying a rectangular prism,
well, the best one here
that is rectangular,
notice, this shape right
here is rectangular
on every side, and it's three dimensions.
It is a prism, and so this
is the rectangular prism.
So let's move that over.
So that
is our
rectangular
prism.
Now, triangular prism.
So this one is interesting.
If you look at this shape right over here,
it has sides that are triangles.
You see this up here is a triangle
and you see this down here is a triangle,
although they're connected
by these rectangular sides.
This is actually what's
called a triangular prism.
In a square pyramid, the
faces which are triangles
all meet at a point.
In a triangular prism, you
have two opposite-facing sides
that are triangles.
You'll see all of these
in different orientations.
Sometimes it'll be resting like this,
sometimes it'll be on it's side,
but this is a triangular prism.
Let me...
So that is
a triangular
prism.
And so we have two left.
You might be able to figure these out.
Which one is a sphere?
When I think sphere, I think of a globe.
This choice right over
here is clearly a sphere.
Let me move that over.
Let me move it over, okay,
so that one is a sphere.
Then last but not least, this
thing that looks like a can
is a cylinder.
So let me move that over.
So that is
a cylinder.
And we're all done.
So these are just useful
names to know for shapes.
Cylinder is...
You have these two faces that are circular
and then they are opposite each other.
It's kind of like a triangular prism,
but instead of having these hard edges
because you have a
triangle, you have a base
that is a circle and a
top that is a circle.